I've got some tour dates I would like to
announce uh July 14th at Edmonton
Alberta Canada
um we'll be in the Great Outdoors Comedy
Festival July 20th at Guilford New
Hampshire
uh August 18th at Windsor Ontario at the
Coliseum
August 20th at Niagara Falls at The
Falls View Casino and August 27th at
Toronto Ontario at Meridian Hall Toronto
my bad Toronto get all your tickets at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r make sure to go through there
and if a place is sold out don't don't
buy the crazy priced ones we will come
back through or hopefully we will also
add some shows thank you we've got some
new merch items to tell you about the be
good to yourself crew neck in teal
it's frosty and we got the new hoodie in
Bitter Sweet plus we've got the root
beer T-shirts from the uh root beer
cartoon all that and more at
theovinstore.com
hey guys I'm in the West Village of New
York City today and uh I am met my
friend Keat she is a
um entrepreneur she has a beautiful
coffee shop and uh flowery or uh Floral
shop called Rosecrans and uh she let us
use this vintage carriage house today
um to record in so very grateful to her
if you want to support her or some of
her businesses in uh The Village in New
York City you can check her out at ad
hoc Collective and we are very grateful
for this beautiful space that we get to
record in today
today's guest is a podcaster and a
personality uh at Barstool Sports and a
personality just
as a human and we're gonna hopefully
learn more about that today she's a
member of the BFFs podcast with Josh
Richards and Dave Portnoy she has her
own podcast as well plan Brie uncut
today's guest is Brianna chicken frogs
[Music]
people and I will find fast forward
um welcome to um the podcast thank you
hey yovon you just let anybody on the
Pod now
we're doing I guess
we do I guess you and I never met no we
haven't yeah it's interesting kinda I
know because I know you threw I know you
threw Caleb CP yeah yeah he's a good guy
he's
a very mischievous that guy I feel like
sometimes you know I feel like sometimes
he's
you know he's kind of a s he's a
slippery guy kind of you know up to no
good you think well he's just really
Sleek I think he's very smart
some people are too smart for their own
good we call them we call him the king
of the tards because he assembles like
he assembles a Crazy Crew yeah and then
he's just the king and everybody worship
so yeah yeah I'm part of it I'm I'm one
of the Taurus oh you're in huh yeah I'm
in you're [__] yeah a little bit
yeah that's good do we have uh I feel
like I'm on one of those rides at Disney
or yeah before they put you in no not
Disney or Universal like at a shitty
Fairground okay
yeah we never met each other before no
never yeah I went to your show though
yeah you went to the show the other
night do you have a good time yeah it
was good it was really funny oh thanks
yeah you're crazy it was long you're
more animated than I thought you would
be oh yeah yeah like you were doing all
these moves and [__] I was like wait
what yeah yeah
um yeah well I have yeah I have
ligaments I have all of it I got you
know or I'm gonna
I guess yeah people maybe think you
would be still or something yeah I don't
know you were just more animated than I
thought yeah you're doing all these
faces really like when you were laying
on the on the chair oh yeah yeah it's
like damn he's animated yeah well I
think you have to keep people's
attention too you know yeah and you're
just one thing and you have to tell a
story with just your body like you only
have so much like you know
you have to I think
um people's attention spans I think seem
short so you want to keep them engaged
yeah you keep me engaged oh good it was
good yeah I'm glad you guys have finally
you've been to a comedy show before yeah
I love stand up I love going I usually
just go to like Open Mic stuff so that
was my first like real big show oh okay
yeah it was good oh yeah because yeah so
I see you on Tick Tock I see you on
Instagram I see like yeah what am I here
why am I here because I just want I feel
like here's why okay so whenever Dave
came on the show he said
um he's like oh we have a lot of Youngs
we make a lot of stars over it uh it
doesn't want his exact words but I was
like you guys you have a good eye for
talent yeah so we're talking about oh
Dave you got a good eye for talent and
he's like yeah we have some great uh
Talent right now and he named a couple
of people but he named you until I was
like oh interesting so I just trust his
eye for talent you know you trust Dave
yeah I think so you think so well yeah
he's found he's found a lot of good
people you had Glennie balls on yeah he
found gunny balls found Caleb yeah found
me I don't know what I'm really doing
they always say I'm doing so well but I
don't I don't really see that yeah I
guess maybe that's what I wanted I was
like who is this gal and then like yeah
what is her what does she do I know
she's like you know I see you just on
the internet so I know she's like an
attractive girl I know that she
you know likes to drink or do drugs or
whatever you know or and you're from
Massachusetts right from Boston yeah
yeah so you could probably drink through
your vagina I mean I don't know
something else there can really they can
do it yeah they'll find they'll get a
beer down yeah I could get it up but no
everyone thinks I do a bunch of drugs I
went I did the nelk podcast the other
day okay and they sent me down they're
just like how much drugs do you do how
much cocaine do you do I don't do drugs
oh really I do well I do shrooms I guess
I don't do the hard drugs okay yeah I
think I'm like a everyone thinks I'm a
big cokehead because my thing is sleep
when you're dead so that's fair yeah
that's a cocaine slogan yeah I know but
it's all I don't do cocaine I got a lot
of more people in my family do drugs
than don't do drugs okay yeah I believe
that yeah so I got a crazy family really
and so now when you say that
um that you don't do drugs are you onto
the info you have any drugs in your
system right now you think uh Adderall
okay yeah how much you think if you had
a guess
Vyvanse 60 milligrams
that seemed like a lot it is kind of a
lot it is I haven't taken it in a while
but I have a long day so I might have a
heart attack or like [__] myself a
little bit yeah yeah so like the vivance
is hard I can't really turn my neck when
I'm on it this [__] gets me real tight
start biting my cheeks and stuff I guess
it's kind of worse than cocaine I opened
it up because I was like maybe I'll just
take half and it's just cocaine in there
oh it is yeah it's all white powder it's
crazy it's kind of scary yeah yeah
anytime like your pers yeah anytime you
get something from like a CVS but it's a
powder it's like yeah it's kind of a
it's kind of scary yeah so I poured a
little I poured half in and it's just
chemicals yeah yeah it's [__] kind of
good though yeah it wasn't bad yeah oh
dude I remember I found the pill on the
uh gym mat one time and I just slurped
it up what was it I don't know well how
do you feel
um could have been
could have been for like erectile
dysfunction could have been a dexa trim
okay but it was good
it was pretty good I thought you know I
felt yeah it was like all right let's
see what God wants to do kind of thing
you know somebody had fallen out of
somebody's pocket at the gym you stay at
the gym longer than you thought uh I
don't remember what happened man I mean
it was probably about seven years ago
but so it's been quite a ride since then
I don't think it's still in my system I
don't know what the half-life of like
something like that is you know yeah no
it's probably only six
um so you are from then so yeah this I
guess I just we just want to get to know
you so okay let's do it you
um yeah and we want to see like where
are you going you know what's going on
with this lady you know okay where am I
up to yeah or just like yeah what is
does this lady have a real plan is this
lady just kind of living willy-nilly you
know like what's some of the goal here I
think okay so how does it start like
when are you a child when am I a child I
was a child when I was a child so I was
just like a small child oh God and the
first are you big born big or not I my
mom was pregnant for 10 months wow so I
was born a month late I was big I was
like 31 inches nine pounds oh my god
really yeah that's real dude I bet they
had you falling into like a Fisherman's
Net yeah
she was real tiny they had to do an
emergency C-section I couldn't fit
through the canal no really yeah that's
crazy so almost like breaking out of a
prison cell yeah I was breaking out of a
prison cell my parents got my parents
should have never got married they got
so they got married when my mom was 10
months pregnant at like a random gazebo
a gazebo in Florida oh yeah they'll
build those anywhere anywhere and she
she had a red she had a red dress on and
they got married and then we came back I
was born and my my family's kind of
crazy I have four I have four siblings
so my oldest sister she's 40. so there's
a big age Gap okay so she's a she's a
black Fisher do you know what a black
black fishing is is that the thing that
uh oh yeah I think it's like it's not
the thing for Sea World it's not the
they're not like the people killing the
no that's worse I think it's she wants
so she she gets level four spray tans so
okay for reference I get level one spray
tan and she'll go and she'll get level
four wow and she gets box braids but
she's white she drives a Chrysler 300
she hangs out with all black Fishers
obviously yeah and she she just got out
of prison she's doing well now but
that's the oldest sister so that was
like my that was my role model growing
up damn yeah she was crazy she was yeah
and she dated a lot of you want to see
her yeah I want to see if you think she
would be black yeah she no she she
doesn't she only dates white guys huh
yeah it's a crazy thing and she hangs
out with all I thought she was hanging
out with all black people but then I
realized they were all black Fishers and
what does black Fishers you mean like
black they're black fishing so you could
this is what you get canceled for
nowadays if you get too dark like spray
tans or if you wear box braids which is
my sister oh I see what you're saying
like people that did the chocolate body
like the bar um weightlifting yeah sir
whoa whoa whoa let me see that's a real
picture of her that's a real picture of
her that's her Facebook that's her
Facebook profile picture she's a white
girl God she's beautiful huh yeah
so that's the oldest sister she's black
fishing
wow and so that's like fishing for black
people like you're trying to catch them
or something like is it like yeah but
she's never but she's only dating white
guys so I don't know what she's trying
to catch yeah that's interesting I never
like we had a lot of like when I was
growing up they just called him kind of
wiggas you know it's like we had like a
lot of wiggas back in the day and it was
like you know you'd see like it was a
lot of first gingers were doing it you
know yeah because I think they were so
white that it almost is like a
like it's everything's a spectrum so I
think if you get so white
you're almost back around to being black
and then sometimes you would see the
black guy that's white you ever see that
guy oh yeah logic yeah but I'm not
talking like a lot like just you know
I'm talking about the guy who like
the guy that looks like you know when
you go see the Tigers and they have that
white tiger and you're like oh wow yeah
like sometimes just the black guy that
has that's complete that's but that's
white you know you don't take them out
yeah it's like uh somebody trapped in a
[Music]
um
yeah it's like uh I don't know what you
would call it
he's a black guy with white skin he
looks complete it's almost like they
took a black eye and they put the
painted painted him white painted them
white yeah I've seen a couple of those
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy right so it's
like a little yeah it's like um it's
almost like something that God got it
like somebody for Christmas or something
like God's like I'm gonna make something
real special for somebody yeah it's like
a unicorn yeah and he made that yeah so
anyway so yeah that's were you talking
about your sister right oh yeah I'm a
family crazy family that's mine okay
she's got a sister that's really out
there yeah yeah I gotta I got they're
all out there I have one good sister I
have another sister they're all gooder
they're not good no I have one good
sister okay okay and then I got two so
we have the black Fisher and then we
have the the next one in age she's crazy
she got gastric bypass surgery oh yeah
and it [__] her up oh yeah it [__]
her up pretty bad she's in she drives a
Vespa and she's she's a lesbian she's
crazy oh yeah yeah she wears sunglasses
all day all day she's insane but that
one that one she's she means well but
she's um she's not doing well now okay
yeah and then we got my good sister and
then I found out I had a brother when I
was 12. no way and what they do they
just like pulled a curtain back and
they're like here he is he showed up it
was crazy the black Fisher they met on
Facebook they met him okay brother yeah
because my dad my dad put the brother up
for adoption when he was like 15 or
something so the black Fisher found this
brother and brought him to Thanksgiving
when I was 12. oh yeah and he looked
just like my dad no and they were like
the same age pretty much damn yeah wow
so that's interesting so a lot was it
was it chaotic or was it fun what was it
like was it pretty cool it was pretty
cool yeah yeah it was pretty cool but I
kind of freaked out and I know we're
living in Boston yeah living in Boston
at the time and what town is he over
living in South Boston okay so South
Boston is like what's it like over there
it's like
um it's like all the people South Boston
used to be all the people that lived in
the projects and then they moved like a
couple streets over okay and we're like
we're doing good and is it whites is it
Brothers what is it it was pretty white
okay yeah it was pretty white town but
then I moved out when I was 12 so I have
like a split life okay because my dad
finally got a job oh he did yeah nice
where do you work at he's a mechanic oh
he is yeah oh yeah my sister used to be
married to a mechanic really yeah and my
mom I think almost dated a mechanic one
time but I don't know if she did or not
but we would always she'd always go
there and take the car in and we'd have
to sit in there sit in the car uh no we
wouldn't say we would sit outside of the
car but I don't know if he was really
fixing it or if they were just kind of
chatting with each other they're always
chatting yeah yeah uh was your dad like
a run around guy did he have a lot of
girlfriends or not
yeah well he was he was like a raging
alcoholic and then I was born and my mom
was like ultimatum oh really her we're
drinking and then he stopped but he did
some other [__] and then he became a
mechanic oh yeah yeah yeah he's still a
mechanic a lot of people that quit doing
drugs they end up I feel like they get
into like mechanic and yeah
um Okay cool so you're in Boston that's
what you're doing right and where did
you graduates from from high school yeah
okay yeah I graduated from high school
and what happened before that like when
did you get like
like when did you start dating or
whatever like when were you when does
that happen like in
I'm a bad I I'm a bad dater I didn't
start dating until I was like a senior a
senior in high school really why not
I was molested by a lot like three
separate three separate lesbians when I
was younger and that's why I can't my
second sister just well I shouldn't say
her name but my second sister she's a
lesbian I was terrified of her my
neighbor Olivia two of the girls so I
would spend all my summers in the
trailer park because that's what my dad
would just drop me off and then he'd go
be a mechanic and my mom was working and
there was a two two separate lesbians at
the trailer park
and what do you think about it and I'm
sorry to hear that no it's fine it's
fine I think I'm better but one night
stands scare me I can't have a one-eyed
stand because it's bringing me back like
it's one time thing oh it's a one-time
thing and the lesbians did that huh yeah
I guess their pedophiles are lesbians
but yeah yeah
lesbians don't get as much pet they
don't get it like that pet they don't
get called a pedophile that much no no
yeah they just called lesbians so when
do you get like your first Brazier or
whatever like do they and how do you
even get that do they like mail it to
you or something like how do you even
get like you gotta oh I stole my first
one really yeah I stole my first one I
was scared so I don't have a good
relationship with my mom so I'm gonna be
like Mom let's go get a bra yeah I was
like Talia my best friend let's go to
the mall let's steal bras yeah yeah we
stole thongs we sold bras I didn't need
one though I still didn't I got a boob
job so I didn't ever need one yeah were
you just very more lean chested kind of
yeah yeah it was lean there was nothing
there damn buddy yeah yeah buddy that's
what everyone called me yeah that's
buddy like damn little brother yeah a
little brother it's like [__] yeah I
always I guess I know I never wondered
that but I guess I was just thinking
about that yeah like do you how do you
get a bra if you're a girl like yeah it
was like the government like mail you
like your first bra or is it like they
give you this book actually in fifth
grade they give all these girls a book
and it like shows you all the different
sizes of nipples and all the different
size of boobs and then it shows you
where you can go yeah it's the best book
ever oh wow that's cool yeah teaches you
about like periods and stuff it does
everything everything and who gives it
to you a parent gives it to the child
I'm sure no it was um it was always the
it was a nurse oh at school yeah that's
cool yeah it wasn't parenting
trying to think what happened at our
school we came in
and they had like a man in there they
would always get like the most
trustworthy man at school who had like
five or six kids and
everybody knew his wife you know and I
remember we came in and this time he had
on sunglasses and he was it was like his
first time teaching sex ed and I think
he was so embarrassed he like didn't
want to be seen doing it or something
but we know it's him right because he's
taught us others yeah yeah we've seen
him and he was up there just like
pointing at all the stuff and everything
and uh people are losing their [__]
minds you know like when kids are
jerking off in the corner like there's
people like wait did you have a jerker
did you have a jerker like did you ever
see the kid jerk off in class
let me thinking oh yeah yeah we had this
one class where people would it was like
the thing to kind of jerk off in your
book oh wow
what class was that uh
uh I don't know no I think it was just
class class is any class yeah it was
like first class and you're like oh what
is this class about like three quarters
of the way through the class you're like
what is this class about they're all
horny yeah yeah just jerking off into
this book well I remember people with
they had a book yeah and people would
try like the goal I think was by the end
of the year to have just somebody like
the conglomerate of Youth and the group
to have jerked off in every pay like to
completely like turn the book into like
a xylophone you know like [__]
you know make it a beautiful Mother's
Day for your mother so
um but yeah I remember that thing got
passed around and until it started to
look like like kind of like uh did you
hit it oh yeah dude I definitely did a
good job on that deal everybody did it
was almost kind of cool at the end of
the year it was almost like having
somebody sign your yearbook oh yeah but
it was all men okay that was kind of the
sad part you know and you couldn't even
fit into your book bag anymore it was
like too big oh dude it was gross yeah
that's gross man have you had any
subscriptions that you forgot about
and you look on your statement and
they've been billing you for months
maybe you gotta maybe you're part of uh
bacon weekly or whatever and they've
been mailing your uh bacon
or maybe you're part of a cold sore
annual
and every year they send you a you know
pictures of the latest uh cs's from
around the world but you forgot and now
you've been paying for it well rocket
money
they can help rocket money will quickly
and easily find your subscriptions for
you and for any you don't want to pay
for anymore you just hit cancel and
Rocket money will cancel it for you it's
that easy
don't let these dark artists
really trap you in
rocket money can help they'll manage all
your finances in one place and
automatically categorize your expenses
you can easily track your budget in real
time and also get alerted if anything
looks off
over three million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
up to seven hundred and twenty dollars a
year
stop throwing your money away cancel on
one of the subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Theo that's
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o rocketmoney.com Theo Laney
Wilson is on tour
if you get a chance that's she's great
070 Shake
phenomenal who else James Blake is
touring
a lot of my favorites are out there
and it's
actually a great time to tell you about
seat geek with over 28 million downloads
SeatGeek is the number one rated
ticketing app there are more than 70 000
events every single day on SeatGeek
including concerts Sports festivals and
more
you know I remember we went to Rufus du
Sol last year or this year I don't know
I went I think I went who knows could
have been dreaming it was great
but we got the tickets off a seat geek
they put all the tickets across the web
in one place and you know I came through
for you guys you can use my code Theo
for twenty dollars off tickets at
SeatGeek that's 20 off your first
purchase with promo code Theo just make
sure you click the link in the
description to download the app code
Theo for twenty dollars off your first
seat geek order oh dude it was gross
yeah that's gross
but yeah so yeah so you go into sex ed
and then what happened
then they just show you the video of
someone giving birth oh immediately
yeah immediately just a full-on birth
and it was like oh so hairy it was so
and they made fifth grade that's too
young I think
you don't even know it is completely
naked completely naked oh yeah and even
they even show the faces and the dad was
holding the hand and everything the dad
was yeah oh wow yeah
and I always wonder who is that woman
who
yeah like who who said who the like we
want to show this to everybody a 12 year
old daughter how much you think she got
paid to do that it's Gotta Be she was
really needed that right
I mean that's gotta be great that's
gotta be crazy the craziest part is to
be if she's at a party or something and
somebody's like hey do you guys remember
Janet and they're like no how will we
know her and then somebody's just like
break yourself in the accordion
yeah does this ring a bell and they just
like oh yeah throw a watermelon out from
behind their leg
yeah so that's a woman that had to do
that I wonder if they even put her in
the credits at the end you know
no way didn't even blur out that's what
I'm saying they showed her whole family
her whole family everyone was here it
was all standing around they're holding
hands the dad's painting is crazy fifth
grade Janet is nuts dude it reminds you
that they had this TV show called hands
on a hard body or it was a movie right
it was like they told these people in
Mississippi if you all show up at like
this Walmart and like put your hand on
this like um
um it was a vehicle it was like a um
Dodge
um it was like a Jeep like a um
it was kind of like a Ford Escort uh
Ford Explorer okay it's like SUV okay
like if you show up at this if you show
up at this small you put your hand on
This SUV the last person with their hand
on gets to keep the SUV right so that
was it that was the rule right so people
showed up and people are [__] washing
their hand and [__] being all fired
up people are doing like this and
getting their hand ready you know and
shaking hands and [__] high five and
doing this just little tricks that don't
mean anything and just getting their
hands ready and then so then they
started off they put like everybody's
got the hand of the car right like two
minutes in one dude's like he takes his
enemies he's like I'm gonna win this
[__] like they're interviewing him his
hands are off because he went like that
it's like you're [__] out of here so
like by 30 hours like people haven't
slept there's like nine people left and
there's this one brother on there and
they keep saying to him man you're gonna
win he's like yeah my friend's bringing
me uh Nestle bar when he gets here with
that [__] it's a wrap right he's like
when I get my sugar up bro it's a
[__] rap for all these [__] right
any other [__] just like a scene like
an old lady who may be dead she's like
they've just leaned her against the back
of it and like two other people anyway
the guy gets there he hands in the nasty
bar he takes his hand off to [__] get
him he's out so anyway that kind of
reminds me like everybody being around
the mom like with their hands on her you
know yeah that's beautiful is kind of
beautiful beautiful yeah
um and so that's how you were born oh no
that's sex head that's sex head yeah but
same thing yeah as I was born fifth
grade and did you like and then so you
had a boyfriend in Senior High School
you said yeah that's when I that's when
I got into the dating okay senior of
high school and do y'all go to a dance
or anything like that you'll go to prom
no no I met him I met him on a cruise
ship when I was 16. and he lived in Ohio
uh so it's a long distance thing there's
a long distance but then I but then I I
backed up and I moved to Ohio for this
man I went to school in Ohio no way
College in Ohio yeah and where'd you
stay at oh you had you had a dorm or
whatever dorm yeah
and then I broke up with him because I
was like this is weird he was way older
than me it was weird what school well
that's probably not that crazy but what
school was the
um what school were you guys at he
didn't go to my college but I went to it
was called Baldwin Wallace Baldwin
Wallace Cleveland it was a small liberal
arts school okay she were artistic and
you like doing RT stuff because why do
you go there then because I followed him
oh yeah so I was [__] and then I was
stuck there oh yeah
and where were you working at
where's I working at yeah it was a nanny
you were I was a nanny yeah oh God where
are those kids now that's crazy yeah
they got their hand on a truck somewhere
dude I had to freaking I didn't nanny or
whatever but like some guy from the gym
hired me to watch his kids for like two
weeks bro
it was [__] so unreal
like it was horrible well I remember
like I feel so bad about this but
I like found like a bunch of porn at the
parents house or whatever and like
so I was just I was torn between like
what you know making sure these kids got
off to school and stuff and then like
like just looking at different
pornography that they had at the house
but what was a guy like the dad their
dad was a nice guy I'd seen him since
later on down the line
everything seemed pretty pretty cool
nice kids kids were cool you know but
they're good now yeah they were good
then wow okay yeah there was no I didn't
affect him in any way how do you talk to
kids like do you know how to talk to
kids
I think I talked to them like adults
really okay you're just like what's up
yeah I think as I feel like if you if
you if you get a kid and you know if you
look at if you really they seem like
oh some of them are [__] idiots you
know but some of them seem like they
know what's up you know yeah
um okay so what else happened then all
right so you're in school where are you
working at I'm working out I'm at
someone's house I was a nanny okay I was
in school I was pre-med though so what
yeah oh so you're smart then yeah I was
biochem Major wow so I was I was doing
all right I was doing all right but I
wasn't like
I wasn't that good I was like bottom of
the class but I still like a three two
okay three two is good though three two
and I was I wanted to be a I wanted to
be a PA so I wanted to go to a PA school
and what is it PA a physician's
assistant okay so it's like the least
time in medical school but you make the
most money so I wanted to do that
because I only had to go to two years of
med school after okay but then I started
making tick tocks okay yeah so I started
making detectives you went from pre-med
to tick tock
fast okay and was your first Tick Tock
like at the pre was it involved in like
medical stuff or notice whatever no I
was just I was uh hung over that was my
thing I was The Hungover girl oh now I
get it yeah yeah that is your thing
you're always like hungover
dang yeah yeah you're always hungover
and having like
travel you're always hung over and
having to like go back into the world
and deal with you whatever is going on
in your life you're like this is how you
like yeah it's kind of like a problem
yeah
this is how you put your neck brace back
on it you [__] had too many white
claws at a prosthetic conference you
know yeah like there's oh yeah now I
really I didn't realize it before yeah
that's what it was now I see yeah it's
like oh okay this is how it goes
interesting yeah so I was a hungover
girl okay see the hunger girl you're
doing tick tocks but then do you feel
like you have to get [__] up though
yeah for sure because that was my that's
why people followed me so I was like
I've always got to be drunk whenever
when people meet me because I'm socially
awkward and on on social media I'm not
socially awkward so when people meet me
and I'm sober they're like whoa you're
weird really yeah yeah why you don't
seem weird right now I don't know I feel
like when I meet people out they want me
to be so like crazy and over the top but
I'm not crazy and over the top in real
life so that's what so I was just drunk
all the time right yeah
yeah you seem like an alcoholic that
like [__] like um commandeered like
an Urban Outfitters a lot of times to me
yeah a little bit yeah yeah a little bit
but I mean and I mean that in like the
sweetest way possible no okay yeah thank
you is it because you feel like you make
the best stuff when you're hungover like
you make like your brain is the most
creative then or something or what do
you think well I was just I was just in
college so I was always hungover so I
just started making videos oh okay I
just was hungover all the time and I
didn't think anyone was gonna follow me
that's why I just I made my [__] chicken
fry and I'm stuck with it oh yeah stuck
with it
yeah because I was thinking I was I
remember asking David I thought it was
like a Native American thing you know I
know you did yeah yeah because I was
trying to think because I grew up around
they had a lot of Native Americans by us
um there's a river in my town it's
called The chafuncta River
and it's named after the chafuncta
Indians right but
they got their name because a long time
ago one of them threw like a big rock
into the water okay and that's the sound
that it made when it went in
yeah and that's what they call
themselves isn't that crazy oh yeah kind
of interesting oh then I should say that
I should make up a cool story about
chicken fry that's right it's not a cool
story what do you think I should say
because everyone asks me and it's not a
cool story yeah I think
it sounds like it could have some um
chicken fry sounds like you could have
some like
maybe some African history to it or some
native history you know it sounds like
it could have
a chef you know maybe Emerald okay maybe
you relate it to like um Wolfgang Puck
or that whatever that guy's name is but
I'm trying to think of what else you
could do with it yeah I want to do
something cool yeah I'm trying I know
and
what about what would other Native
American names be for like the other
people at Barstool oh
like
do you think they all start with
ouch do you think they all start with
like it's the sound it's the tribe we
got
uh oh
Dave yeah because he gambles and he and
he sold the business for a lot of money
maybe yeah
uh
cheese uh yeah to cheese cheese to
cheese yeah yeah definitely cheese
because he went when he was on here he's
telling me he went to a cheese shop he
knows a lot of um he knows a man is a
cheese Monger okay who is somebody who
like
is like basically the Batman of cheese
right and so he went and hung out with
that like like Glenn he went to like a
[__]
lady's like I'm walking down the street
some guy pops out of a cheese shop like
the head of cheese like Mr Cheese
[__] Like Larry queso's [__] white
boss you know like he [__] pops out
you know [__] Ronnie mozzarella pops
out of the back and he's like this way
son and he like took him into the back
of like a cheese world and then he said
he sat in like a beautiful that's a real
story it's the first story he told me he
goes we sat in a beautiful table and the
guy keeps bringing out different cheeses
in this and that and gruyere and grew
here and grew everywhere like he's just
like every type of cheese came out you
know and then like three hours later
they just like threw him back out into
the [__] Street and he was done never
saw him again never saw him again like
it all didn't even happen oh that must
have been a good day for Glennie though
oh it was he was so excited you know
yeah so he's cheesed yeah he's the
cheese you have to change to cheese
what do you think Caleb would be
um
maybe to cheerful no he's too cheerful
he is pretty careful cheerful and he
wasn't really a quarterback in college
he was a basically the first male
cheerleader at the University of North
Carolina
but he doesn't like to say that though
we were out we were out a couple
weekends ago and um the owner of a bar
he brought out Caleb's Jersey that he
made him sign
he brought it out to him he's like I'm
just like I really respect you like you
gotta sign it Caleb like brings out the
Sharpie and he couldn't think of what's
right on he was so embarrassed he was so
embarrassed but he signed it it was
clean it was probably his original
jersey and it was still clean I'm sure
he was like there's only two
that's funny so yeah maybe you should
cheerful I don't know if the cheerful is
exactly it I'm not saying it's not
cha cha I feel like he's like a
Cha-cha-cha guy he's a dancer I don't
know I saw him win twenty thousand
dollars at a casino
and then try to buy the late the the
card tender or whatever her name is uh
Kia Sorrento okay Sorento yeah really
was she offended well he still I won't
he's like I'm buying this [__] I could
get a serrano and that's when people are
like you gotta leave like yeah get the
[__] out of here and literally you can
see how bummed out she was because she
knew she was about to get a Kia Sorrento
but just because he called her a [__]
The Pit Boss is like we don't use that
language around here oh [__] she's
waiting in the parking lot dude it's
like dude you can call me a [__] if you
can get me a [__] Kia sorry call me
whatever yes you needed that yeah oh
[__] Kia Sorrento was also we had a that
KIA company they named their cars I feel
like after a lot of like black girls
that went to my high school Kia Sophia
Kia Sorrento what's the other ones at
Forte
oh yeah Kia Optima dog you telling me
Kia Optima didn't [__] play
basketball for the Women's Basketball
team at my high school you out of your
mind because well that's my sister
that's cute yeah it is
but she's having a Chrysler 300. so did
she throw up gang signs and stuff or
what does she like I stay away from her
she's crazy man she's so crazy there was
a whole time she was on she's been doing
she's she was going through it all she
was on there was a period [__] dude no
but there's a period of time where she
was doing meth or something and she
thought she shaved her head she shaved
it because oh wow yeah she thought there
was people talking to her it was sad but
then she like she dropped off her um her
TV at my house all of her phones she's
like they're listening you gotta take it
she was deep huh yeah she was deep but
she's good now but it was great it was
crazy to watch wow yeah but she's black
fishing sober and so black fishing is
when you try to go to the black side you
try to be black I think yeah or you want
you want to be perceived as black but
then if anyone were to be racist you'd
be like what take a makeup wife and be
like I'm white oh I see what you're
saying yeah yeah
I think sometimes man when I was young I
related to a lot of the black kids so
much I would
but then when it came down to it one
time me and this my friend Devin we were
fishing and
uh and he was black and some white kid
guy was throwing rocks up from this
railroad track down bus we're official
on this bank and he started calling us
the n-word right and I was like not me
you know what I'm saying just Devin you
know what I'm saying like
you know like I was like I was down with
Devin until that part of that I was like
I mean [__] the guy throwing rocks you
know the guy's a piece of [__] but at
the same time like that ain't me yeah
yeah I don't include you know what I'm
saying like that's when I realized I'm
only there you know he was my friend and
I was gonna rock with him but so you
wouldn't Blackfish I wouldn't Blackfish
yeah I would fish with blacks yeah sorry
I stepped on your jokes that's okay yeah
I didn't realize it that's a funny joke
yeah that's a good one yeah so you
wouldn't black fish no no but I would
fish with the blacks
wait what's it like hanging out with
Comics our Comics cool
you like them
you like yourself
oh I don't know about that let's start
with other people that's safe okay uh
let me think do I like hanging out the
comics yeah I think Comics are
intrinsically kind of alone but like
liked or do they do a lot of stuff by
themselves
so I think well yeah I Feel Like Comics
always want this big like oh we're so
we're so dark and sad and lonely but
like are they every single one of them
I don't know
I I think a lot of them have or a lot of
them probably have a lot of like strange
stuff or weird things that they that
they ended up needing to go get people
to look at them you know
you know what I'm saying yeah I think so
so I think someone probably have some
dark stuff like that you know I bet
someone probably have some pretty dark
things so I think there's probably some
truth to that but I think also now
there's there's a lot more like
people that are funny from like Tick
Tock from like short clips from like
different things like that
so I think you're getting like a lot
more um
like
I don't even know if
like I don't know if if there's as many
if I'm starting out now as a comedian I
wonder do I try and get on stage which
is where you learn to be a comedian
right
or do I just try and get in front of my
phone that's true well also as because
you do stand up and everything do you do
you like respect the people that start
on tiktok because I know a lot of
stand-up comics that are like they hate
people that start on Tick Tock and then
bring a crab to a show
that's a good question I remember I got
jealous when there was a lot of
YouTubers there was like um Roman Atwood
uh
uh Dennis Roman and Dennis were partner
Dennis Rody
um Fouseytube some of those guys were
touring and going to comedy clubs right
and they would do their shows during the
day even a lot of times and I was
envious really I mean I was jealous you
know because they were having more
success like you had Comics you've been
on the road for like nine years going to
these clubs and then these guys were
showing up and having their audience
come see them at a comedy club
so I think that's what made it a little
strange first so it's the comedy club
well it was like oh you're doing it at
our space yeah okay but those clubs just
happen to be kind of the size for the
audiences they were bringing so that's I
never really thought about why there was
there was like in the beginning there
was like some angst towards for me
anyway I think a lot of people felt that
way a lot of comedians felt that way it
was angst towards some of the uh
vloggers yeah for sure because it was
like [__] their son at my club for like
a five o'clock show because some of
their audience would be children so they
do a daytime show yeah and then they did
they they did they do a daytime show
comedy though or they were just getting
up there and they would get up on stage
and like shoot a T-shirt cannon or
something you know okay or [__] you
know or do like a cheer I don't know
what they were doing yeah like Body
Rolls yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is way weird to do for a [__]
bunch of children it's so weird they
still do that it's crazy it's crazy
I guess there's people still body
rolling up oh they're still bottles why
I don't know because it sells it works I
mean look look at them they were selling
out the comedies the comedy stories
you're up there all mad
that's true yeah and I was outside I was
waiting for my show which was at seven
o'clock that nobody was coming to
because I'm like these [__]
they're out there hitting it on the
streets on a body roll so yeah yeah like
it doesn't look natural you don't met
Nelly so I think uh
I think they're maybe I think there
could be
some angst about a I think at that time
there was probably some angst about it
but now I think that it's
it's almost like you go there first yeah
a lot of comedians aren't thinking that
you go to the stage first I think
there's some
if you're a comedian right now who does
who's working really hard on the clubs
but you're having trouble on social
media it must be extremely
frustrated I'd be mad because there's
well I mean a lot of the stand-up comics
that do like Tick Tock first they just
have their few clips that go viral and
then people will come see them and they
won't be funny
right yeah that's another problem I
think is scary if you get more popular
than where you can support it with your
own comedy yeah I see that a lot you do
yeah yeah I went to I see a bunch of
people because I follow I mean I'm
friends with a bunch of influencers and
Tech talkers so I'll follow them on Tick
Tock and like I'll see their stand up on
Tech talk and then you go see them and
it's like those same jokes that went
viral that's like they're two big hits
in the show and then the rest is just
like a lull
yeah but I think some people I don't
even know if like a real young audience
if they even know like
that there is this whole stand-up comedy
thing or do they just think I'm gonna go
see these two hits I'm gonna have a
blast while I'm there I'm gonna capture
it on my phone on socials and then
that's going to be that well yeah they
must not because they keep going like
the lines are around the block and stuff
so I guess like a live podcast is what
they think it is yeah
but there's something really special
about seeing
um
if there's somebody you watch on Tick
Tock and social media and you enjoy them
right there's something on a podcast or
something I've sat in the audience I've
like sat in the audience before and been
like oh man this is so cool I watch this
guy I'm involved in their life for this
girl and then I get to be in the same
room as them it almost sometimes there's
part of it it doesn't really matter what
they're saying like it'd be great if the
material is also great but just being in
the same room as them it's almost like
you get like a moment like in in like in
reality like it's cool it's cool they're
always on a screen right and then
they're right there it's like oh this is
cool it's kind of like you for me that's
true right yeah yeah because we've never
even seen it I felt like I was like this
morning I was like yeah I can't remember
the last time that I saw this lady and
then I was like oh I never saw this lady
I kind of felt the same way I was like I
feel like I I saw this guy before but I
never saw this guy yeah I never saw this
guy no no um but I know some of you are
even just watching you like I see some
just like some of your mannerisms are
the same but
um which makes sense because that's you
um okay so what happened then you were
in high school oh yeah I was in high
school and and you got a boyfriend in
your senior year did y'all fall in love
you think oh and then you moved to Ohio
for the man yeah wow so you were in love
then I was in love I think so and do
y'all get engaged at all no crazy no no
but yeah I moved there I think I was
pregnancy scares or not oh I think I'm
infertile okay there you go yeah I know
a little no Easter over here yeah
it's tough but it's already got that no
Easter honor oh man
but no no no pregnancy scares um but I
was dating for two years and I realized
I don't I don't know why I went to
school for this man I don't know why I
went to Ohio out of everywhere so I
broke up with him but I stayed in Ohio
okay and then I got another boyfriend in
Ohio okay and are you that kind of
person you jump from boyfriend to
boyfriend yeah really I'm a relationship
girl you are yeah but do you leave any
time like is there there's an overlap
usually no oh no
every time so you are okay that's not
gonna overlap that's called I think I
don't know what the term for it is now
what do they call it that overlap
that's interesting there's been a few
yeah there's well there's only been a
few overlaps do you let the men meet
each other like in passing like is there
like a moment where you get out of one
car and into an like you know is there
that at least give them in that moment
the first there was a the first one yeah
there was an overlap meeting really yeah
no way what happened well because I
usually just I just date my friends so
like we'll be in the same friend group
and then they'll all know each other
there will always be that overlap and
the guy the guy dating currently usually
can tell that I'm gonna want to date the
friend no way really yeah but I'm saying
like always it's been like three times
okay yeah
it's been like three overlaps but that
seemed like a pretty decent amount I
think like I'm not a detective or
anything right I don't even know any I
mean I know one guy he's not a detective
but he'll [__] he'll find out but um
when he hears this he will you know
but definitely
um what were you talking about oh yeah
yeah dude you gotta [__] let them
meet each other sometimes yeah yeah just
like um and it seemed like you might
have a problem then yeah yeah do you
think you do yeah well I just have
commitment issues oh yeah
yeah you know come on yeah yeah I just
have commitment as you saw I feel like
I'll be in these relationships and I'm
so worried aren't you so worried do you
want to get married
not today if that's what you're asking
eventually oh yeah I thought you were
asking me no I have um
I would like to get married
yes but I think if I want to get I'm so
scared you get married and then like
three weeks into the marriage you find
that person that's like oh that's I
should have married that guy what you
can't do that though that's why I don't
I know yeah see that's well yeah but
there's always going to be more of that
guys you know I know
but do you
let me think about it so you get into a
mirror
all right you walk down the aisle
everything right everybody's singing
everybody's having a blast right you
partying the the uh
car pulls up the mafia car you get in
takes you guys only two blocks away then
you get back and walk back out it's just
for pictures but still right you're off
right you did the wedding thing there's
a [__] guy with a Tommy Gun
somebody's stepdad is out there [__]
shooting it shooting at the moon right
because he's been doing coke at the
[__] nuptials but whatever
everybody's [__] having a good time
right and then
um
two weeks later Yuri yeah you're out of
uh Buca Di beppa or something with your
husband hey if I can see
there's a waiter and you're like oh I
should have married that guy yeah I
don't know if it's a waiter maybe the
chef something okay I'm just worried I
just get worried you married the wrong
person that's scary
right it is yeah it's real scary
um
yeah I don't know did you ever go to
therapy about it do you really think
that or not yeah no I really think that
but [__] dude because then your husband
how's he always going to be able to make
sure that he's the right guy then I know
well I think it was because so when I
was talking about earlier my parents
I've never they were married for 18
years my first 18 years of my life but I
never even saw them kiss oh yeah one
time 18 years I don't even think they
hugged not even a smile so I had this
whole thing that marriage is terrible so
I'm trying to turn the leaf I'm trying
to I'm trying to think maybe maybe it's
okay be trying to evolve there yeah I'm
trying to evolve in that yeah that
aspect you need like a new like a
springtime in your heart yeah yeah yeah
or Primavera that's what they call it
okay in Spain Primavera I need that
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
you know uh I got therapy today actually
just remember got therapy today at 6 00
PM I'm gonna do that therapy be a
therapy baby be a therapy boy
you know I need help I didn't I quit
pretending I don't
I quit pretending I can do everything
myself I never have my whole life
I've always thought I'm doing this alone
I'm not
there's other people helping me whether
I realize it or not and that's why I
need to just make sure that I stick with
that idea that I'm getting help from
myself I'm not doing life alone
it's no fun and it's impossible
better help can set you up with a
licensed therapist that's right
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and swiss therapist at any time for no
additional charge find more balance with
better help visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o to get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p-help.com Theo
yeah I think I I only saw my mom and dad
kiss one time my dad kissed my mom on
the top of her head okay it was one of
our birthdays or something
and my mom let him that was a crazy
thing yeah like the whole time my dad's
lips are getting close to her head we're
all like somebody's gonna get the [__]
now yeah right we knew it dude
and I remember reaching over and my mom
had like this fancy cake cutting tool
and it like it was an old-fashioned when
it had these prongs that went straight
down it was almost like a pick like a
hair pick okay and there were sharp
metal ones and it was like a she
probably got it somebody had died and
she got it right and so I knew I [__]
remember reaching for that thing and
just moving it out of her way like as I
saw my dad slipped head towards her head
I'm like somebody's gonna [__] get
hurt I was gonna die but she took it
yeah I was like my dad's about to
[__] lose that brain cake that he's
got bro she's got a [__] slice that
thing up but she had had half a cup of
champagne and she [__] took it okay
so that's the only time you saw them
kiss yep and that was love man that was
my definition of right there there was
like Weaponry yeah there was a lot of
uncomfort yeah there was a lot of
uncertainty if if it's okay
um there was a lot of like uh
tons of fear around I mean yeah I think
that's the all that's the closest I ever
saw my parents get and then my dad he
had to sleep on the couch yeah I thought
he lived on the couch right I did that
too really my dad lived on the couch
yeah and then he moved to the basement
because it was darker down there oh
really dead yeah and I remember I was
like the one time I was like my oh
they're doing well is when my mom would
let me sit in the back seat but like
when we would travel together usually I
would sit in the front seat my mom would
sit in the back and my dad would drive
but when my mom sat in the front I was
like oh
yeah yeah it was good oh that's cool
yeah moving to the basement's almost
like because it's darker down there it's
almost like I want to kill myself but
I'm gonna stay alive yeah yeah it's one
of those yeah
wow that's crazy yeah I remember at
Christmas we would have to go out to the
Christmas tree that was out there by my
dad right so we're like [__] dad is
guarding the tree but my dad was
you know my dad was very old when I was
when he was 70 when I was born so at
this time he was like
76 or 75 right how old is your mom my
mom was 32 so they had 38 years
difference which is a lot of times
um
and anyway we would have to sneak out
like past my dad right and sometimes
he would [__] wake up and ask us like
what was going on they were like it's
[__] it's Christmas
to him and [__] like he didn't know what
the [__] was going on was he like
because he was so was he like Cena he
was getting kind of senile yeah
I remember one time we went
trick-or-treating and uh
we got all dressed up and we let and my
dad sometimes my mom like she would make
my dad do things but she knew he
couldn't do them right so it was like
she would kind of set him up for failure
in a weird way
she was like I need you to get the kids
Halloween costumes
um
and bring him home tonight's Halloween
right yeah so my dad he liked to drink
sometimes in Parker's car in the ditch
right there's like two of his favorite
things to do
and so he would come home with the
Halloween costumes and it would be [__]
like like me and my brother were both
Raggedy Ann right so like just whatever
he [__] found like no it was always
the worst Halloween costume like one can
of like spray paint one time wasn't even
like the stuff you're supposed to put on
the kids or whatever
oh dude one of my sisters had a [__]
pigtail that that I remember Mom had to
cut off and we kept her for like 15
years
um I had the same witch costume
like 12 years and it started not fitting
anymore it was so itchy I was like
please can I be something else please
and then I was a milk carton I had a
paper mache it it was so bad dude you're
not even a witch at that point you're
just an itch is scratching it
[Laughter]
um
but then I remember we went we were
finally got out and we get out and go
trick or treat and we came back then
we're like we're gonna come back to our
own house we're gonna surprise dad right
so we go up to the door we knock he
opens the door
and he just gives us can he doesn't even
[__] realize that it's us he [__]
gave us we're good and just wishing he
had we just left like 22 minutes ago in
the costumes that he [__] bought us
dude
yeah with my sister's [__] rock hard
pigtail like this you're covered in
spray paint oh
I was like God he doesn't even know
um
that's crazy it was interesting
so what happened then so you're making
tick tocks people are like she's
attractive she's creative there's
something Charming about her we don't
know what it is she doesn't know what it
is but we love it right yeah I guess so
okay it was more the girls the girls
love me so my whole demographic is like
I think it's 92 female really yeah and
the the newest eight percent was only
since I got a boob job are you serious
yeah guys hate me barcel hates me really
the whole demographic hates me yeah I
don't know we shouldn't have had you on
this I know I know
that's why I'm like why am I here
well Dave I respect Dave's eye for
talent he said this girl no he loves me
I mean okay so Dave brought a new
demographic to Barstool what demographic
was it all the girls all the girls
people that had been molested basically
by lesbian pedophiles than a black
fishing sister with a Chrysler 300
that's who I brought to [__] bar
stool but no well I was the top I was
the top Creator at Barstool last month
so I mean really nothing has to be doing
good nice so we're right on Trend then
yeah no we're good we're good
um so I was like maybe you're trying to
get a tick tock audience I don't know
what you were doing with me here
yeah no I don't know I mean I know what
I'm doing we want to to meet you because
we don't know you and
um
yeah we wanted to learn about you I
think we're doing that okay yeah yeah we
just learned about Glenny balls not long
ago and it was so much fun it was
honestly one of the funnest interviews
that ever had really
yeah I mean yeah there's just something
about the guy and he came out to us he
came out to the show the other night out
in Westbury he had like four of his
friends with him her mommy's act to send
a picture too so we can put it in
um and that was great they were all
going they were yeah driving I think
Canada or something like for some rare
meat festival or something or something
you know they were doing something
somebody was opening up like a like a
special Olive shop or something
somewhere
Windsor Ontario something yeah they're
[__] driving along when you meet
somebody who's driving cross-country for
a [__] new condiment yeah it's
[__] interesting yeah that's a good
episode but there's something so
Charming about there's just something
yeah there's something awesome about
that guy you know he he like he pulls
girls hard like really hot girls too
really yeah it's good great pork too huh
yeah that's just an old pulled pork joke
and I'm just joking Glennie I I believe
he does well he's handsome for one and
his mother loves him there's something
unique about a kid lovable guy yeah very
lovable lovable very [__] lovable in
fact I don't even think
yeah I could see somebody being married
to him and they didn't realize that it
had it's like oh damn I just loved him
so much now we're married yeah you know
yeah that's like the guy in passing
that's him that's plenty
yeah Glenn yeah there's just something
real special about him
um so anyway what else were we saying
we're talking about something and then
we kind of went on to that
oh we're talking about bar stool
let's do this then how about if you had
to people do [__] America all the time
but what about if you had Glenny okay
right
um
Frank oh oh we don't get along
wait till the game wait till I announce
all three Glennie Frank and then Dave
yeah
what the hell I think they're I love it
all right oh my gosh
I'm gonna kill
I'm gonna kill Frank
God I'm gonna kill him he ain't gonna
live that long
I can't he's he's gonna die so we're
gonna kill him okay we're not this is
you yeah I'm sorry sorry I'll I'll
probably marry Dave yeah okay smart he's
got a lot of Celtics teams smart yeah
and then uh
for sex that leaves me with plenty for
sex yeah
it's not bad though no it's not bad what
would you do it's a summer sausage thing
you know yeah
um would I do those three yeah
Mary I don't know
I don't think Dave and I would get along
that well if we were married no no why
would you butt heads about you think
and uh
I just think
I mean I admired it I look at Dave
honestly as a kind of like a Paul Revere
type of figure he re he you know he's
crazy he's crazy but he's he says what
he wants to say and he stands up for he
stands behind what he wants to say if he
makes mistakes he makes mistakes but
he's Brave in that sense I really admire
that about him I'm team Dave I love Dave
so
um yeah but I don't think we could be Ma
I mean I don't want to be married to a
man either
so this game [__] sucks bro I mean
yeah for me too yeah yeah but at least
you got a man on the other end of it you
know I guess that's true
um maybe Frank I don't know if Frank
what is like kind of habits are at the
house
I think he's tidy
I don't know
think so you think he did a live stream
from his apartment but it's when he
first got it oh yeah he got a dishwasher
yeah yeah but that's
it is nice yeah I like having a good
dishwasher let me think I would probably
kill
I don't want to have sex today because
I've seen some of his sex videos and
some of it seems like
yeah too much it just seems a lot
especially if I'm a man and he's a man
you know what I'm saying like yeah if
you do the body math it's gonna be a
[__] it's gonna be it's gonna be a
weird equation so I don't want that I
don't think I want to be a part of that
okay I'd have to I guess I would have to
kill him maybe okay
and then I'll probably marry Glenny yeah
and then I smash big Frank yeah you
rather okay yeah I would just [__]
you smash him I think I'd have to yeah
yeah you know
yeah that's not bad I don't think so and
I don't know him either so it could be
like you know you blindfold everybody
everybody
and him yeah but it seems like it's a
lot of him I think that's why I said
that but yeah I think you blindfold
everybody and then you just kind of hope
for the best yeah no he's yeah he
screams a lot he's crazy yeah he's kind
of crazy so yeah I think I would just be
in and out of there man yeah go hit it
and quit it yeah and have you on the
quit it yeah yeah keep them blindfolded
get out of there so okay so you quit
working at the um so then do you quit
college completely and then how did you
get over to New York yeah I was still in
school when bars the bar stool gave me
an internship so I had an internship for
like a week in Ohio yeah so she was like
the bar still girl in Ohio oh people you
must have been like that it must have
been insane you're in college at the
time yeah wow yeah that was cool people
must have [__] went ape [__] yeah I
hated it it was so bad I stopped going
out no way that is when you go out no I
hated it I told you I'm like so I'm
awkward I hated it everyone just wanted
to like take pictures and stuff and I
was it was so awkward really I hated it
yeah so I stayed home and well that's
when I started my podcast I was like
well I have to do this if I want to do
it so I was just making about I was
making like five videos a day and then
um
okay and then I moved I I moved to New
York and your podcast was what plan B
plan Brie yeah you still have it yeah
okay I didn't know that yeah
um
and then so then you got your own
podcast going it's on bar stool it's on
Barstool yeah okay and I uh and you
moved to New York City yeah I tried to
do both I tried to do school and bar
stool but I realized I was never gonna
get into PA school with my content so I
dropped out of school and then I moved
to New York by myself
yeah and what did your mom say
she still doesn't get it she doesn't
know she's older she's um she's like 65.
so she doesn't she doesn't understand
what's going on but once I started like
paying all my own bills she was just
like this is good you can do it okay all
good and um yeah she still has no idea
she doesn't know what barcelage she
doesn't have she doesn't even know how
what a podcast is really yeah she'll
never hear any of this uh-uh what does
she do then where did she is she in a
facility is she she got a no she's laid
up she got a double knee replacement oh
yeah dude you gotta [__] who talked
her into that she's crazy she got a
double knee replacement but she took a
look around
everyone else and she only she's Brave
she only took Tylenol after it so she's
been all laid up she goes to the um she
goes to the Y every day and swims oh I
love the ones she's retired she's in
there every day swimming at the water
really every day oh that's cool that's
what she does though but she doesn't
know what I do and she's in Suffolk
County
yeah she's in Plymouth County Plymouth
damn they got a good y up there yeah
Hanover why she loves it I love YMCA's
man you do you go oh we used to go all
the time it was like the place we would
[__] go boy it's where I learned
everything yeah I used to get a day pass
yeah yeah oh the poor moms would drop
their kids off at the [__] YMCA yeah
you would walk between there and they
would kick out of there and you have to
go to the library you know I remember
being the library and be like where can
we swim and they're like this is a
[__] life into the back with like the
daycare but it's like it's just like 11
year old kids watching smaller kids they
all have smocks on for some reason so I
just walk in and put a smock on I was
just there and then I would sneak to the
pool and they never let you go off the
diving board though yeah yeah they and
they shouldn't I was like you're gonna
[__] draft yeah that's true
um
yeah especially if you if the person on
the diving board looks like the same
person who's about to jump off a
building it's really the same look if
you ever see somebody about to jump off
a building like I don't know if I could
be doing this yeah this is the same look
as a kid that shouldn't be going off
that board it's terrified
um yeah dude the YMCA man I fell in love
with a girl there one time because she
um
she had tits right nobody'd ever seen
them ever I mean none of our friends I
remember we came we're like damn what's
wrong with her you know I think she has
cancer like on her chest like beautiful
cancer you know because she just had
these you know she had them growths on
her we'd never seen it and uh
she ended up getting killed years later
oh I know it wasn't cancer
I don't know what got it that'd be crazy
if it was but
she got murdered or she what if it was
breast cancer that she died I hate to
say that because it's very sad and it
takes a lot of people but
I wouldn't be shocked that she had so
much as young was she with the breasts I
mean I don't know
we didn't know what they were like I
remember were they like somebody thought
she was having twins or something
because you saw like two heads coming
out of her body where there's veins we
didn't see him that good
damn I mean we drew so many pictures of
them
it was [__] guessed what they were
like boy I guess yeah like I remember we
shake each other and be like describe
our [__] tits to me like we were like
we really really were excited you know
we couldn't help but we were just human
males yes
um how old when you're a human male how
old do you start getting excited about
tits
like when are you like whoa
well I think there's two things or one
there's like a physiological part of it
physiological is that a word that
physiological physiological
your body you can't help it
like you'll be like um
your all your blood will run to the like
all your blood will run to the front of
your body if a woman's around okay like
literally you'll feel the back of your
body just kind of [__] like sag a
little like you're just yeah go cold
like you're so there's just you can't
help that right and so and that's what
happens with your wiener your wiener is
just the it's like the I was a
forerunner for it yeah it's like uh you
know on a turkey whenever it gets warm
enough in that thing pot it's just like
that it's like this is like some of the
blood's like hey we found a way it's
like hey this is as far as we can go you
know oh yeah just yeah just an arrow
that's it it's like yeah it's like over
there yeah oh okay yeah so uh so that
happens but then there's another there's
like a visual thing that's kind of
happens I think
um
when somebody has brat and you start to
see them you know and then your real
kind of so there's that thing going on I
think there's two things but I don't
know what age it's at
just whenever you hit whenever you hit
puberty
but it can be before that if somebody
like gets you real visually intrigued so
you're almost intrigued from like a
curious standpoint because you know one
day you can you're gonna care writer you
just wonder what's going on here
something's changing I want to know I'm
curious what's happening
um and then I was at summer camp and
they had a guy and he was dating one of
the counselors and like you said it was
through YMCA so it was just like yeah
they're just like the oldest kids right
and he would let us look down his
girlfriend's shirt for a little while no
yeah
yeah his girlfriend yeah yeah he like
kind of got off on it or something at
the park
so I remember especially if it rained
out and there was anything for us to do
we'd let us get in line and look did you
look yeah look dude dude it was so
awesome I couldn't even see that's how
awesome it was like
I would look and I was [__] we were
done I was blind about my own excitement
for it like [__] dog I'd be like dude I
didn't see him he's like you just
[__] looked like but I [__] didn't
see dude you playing
damn you're so excited oh yeah we were
God we were so excited
um okay so what happened then so you get
so now you're in New York you're living
there and who'd you choose to live with
and how did you find a place uh well I
moved here during covid so no one lived
here okay it was the easiest time to
move here it was scary though because no
one was here but Apartments were half
the price so I moved in to the shittiest
apartment it was disgusting there was
like cockroaches there was holes in the
wall it was so bad and I I called my
best friend and I asked her to drop out
of school and move to New York with me
and she did
now is that a best friend or is that
somebody who is
a product of the system like what are we
looking at here
um yeah well she works at barcel now I
got her a job you did yeah oh wait
what's her name Grace oh I think I seen
her maybe she's my um she's my co-host
yeah yeah yeah she's the redhead yeah
yeah she's Irish she's Irish she's Irish
yeah yeah beautiful young lady she seems
like uh you guys have a lot of good time
together yeah so she's a she's a she's a
down girl but it could have went really
bad she was door dashing when she she
moved here really so she couldn't what
do you mean knocking and running off or
whatever
yeah no no she was uh she was on foot
delivering food oh really on foot on
foot oh my God it was on foot she would
have to go and remember it was like
Super Bowl Sunday and she had to go from
like the top of her dad
to like [__] to [__] try back out
on foot in her Sorel snow boots she did
like she was on foot for like three
hours but she only made one delivery
because she had to go so far
so far psychopath yeah and she still
couldn't pay rent yeah no [__] dude well
she could have if she'd have been
sponsored by North Face dude how [__]
far is that track that's gotta be it was
it had it been a three hour Trek on foot
and she would come home and she'd come
home she'd be like purple it was so bad
it was so bad and I'd come home like ah
I'll get you a job one day
what about you get there and they're
like you forgot the sauce and then you
just literally take a sword out and just
take your own life right there it was
close to that it was close to that yeah
it was crazy but she's not doordashing
anymore she I got her a job she deserves
a job but I got it for her yeah I mean
there should be like I think in the
future so many people do doordash and
stuff now you know I think there will be
a competition if they're smart they'll
turn into a competition where it's like
how do you get this chalupa right
through these different obstacles and
get it to yes yeah or like some type of
way to do it if they started to make
like a cool of like a series of events
out of it yeah like a American Ninja
Warrior yep but sometimes yeah like a
like a course yeah through the park
American Ninja Warrior yeah daughter oh
okay sorry no it's okay let's see a
little bit gay it's okay dorier dorier
because of doordash you know yeah
it wasn't that good it wasn't yeah
well here's the thing about doordashing
is Do you have a doordash
no I'll tell you what I did though
I uh
I used to do pizza I was in pizza sales
right okay
and
um
the manager or the assistant manager on
Sunday he was a
um
a BAC right he's born again Christian oh
okay and so we would do fake orders that
came in and like oh we gotta call in
from like uh
Ricky Gervais or something right in our
town it was like a small town right like
out on like
million dollar Road right like they had
a place bus called million dollar Road
um
but it would be like middle of nowhere
and these were people real names
celebrities right okay but he didn't
know any celebrities because he was only
through the church everything he saw was
so if you'd have been like Paul the
Apostle you know down on Main Main
Street he'd have been like oh insane
right but if you were like Ricky
gervaisi had no idea if you were like
um Sam Elliott he had no idea you know
so he would drive off and go deliver the
stuff and we would um we would deep fry
everything in the place
uh like any type of meats or even
pudding if you put it in a deep fried
it'll fry okay so we had a fried pudding
chunks and be drinking just draft beer
oh nice and he'd come back we'd be so
[__] up right we'd be just like off
the foil oh he'd come rolling back in
and be like Ricky or girvayas doesn't
want to spy and we were I just ripped at
that point yelling like obscenities and
[__] at him and he'd get all pissed off
at us so I worked there
I had to work at I was court-ordered to
work at um the Water Treatment Facility
in our town that was like a big thing
okay what'd you have to do
just watch a water okay make sure it was
clean
um
get you know you would net it and stuff
like that get stuff out of it okay uh
which is pretty crazy because we would
miss a lot of stuff too
um
but
what about yourself
I was uh I worked at a fast food
restaurant I was a um I was like the the
girl that yelled the numbers but I was
too like someone's number you'd be like
number 45 but I was two I was too
nervous to yell them what yeah I was too
nervous I was so weird as a kid I was
like so insecure and scared so I
wouldn't yell it I'd be like number 45
and I just like I'd like find I'd like
look for people that were like looking
waiting for their order and I just give
it to them like oh they need it yeah and
then I was a nanny I was a bottle girl
that was really that was terrible was
that after you got your breasts or not
really flat bottle girl flat bottle girl
and I refused I was the only bottle girl
you don't have to have to wear those
like leotards yeah I refused I just wore
a dress
really yeah well I had like a had like a
big Bombshell bra so it looked like I
had something going on right but you
were in a yeah you were kind of like the
um
who's uh I'm trying to think of
that woman who sings that song uh
the dog days are over you know what I'm
talking about no idea yeah you're like
the Florence and the Machine of the
bottle girl okay staff does that make
any sense that reference that yeah okay
thanks
um she was like kind of like almost like
he had a little bit more of a hippie
Vibe yeah he's like the one hippie
bottle girl yeah and I would always get
the good tables too really yeah I have
little John like I would get a little
John I would get all the Celtics players
and all the like it was fun but I hated
it the girls were mean yeah they were so
mean I hated it so I quit and then um
then I went to school I was a bartender
um
um yeah that bottle girl it's a it's an
interesting industry being caught up in
that I think
yeah it's like
it's like real estate agents because
everyone was like everyone's area was
there like real estate and they were
real they were like real protective over
it yeah so if you like stepped over to
the wrong side of like the Dance Floor a
girl would come over and she'd like I
got into a lot of tussles really yeah
yeah it was scary and the the management
doesn't care they're just like give me
all your money and then you gotta stay
till six in the morning and you gotta
count all the money
it's a whole thing and are people doing
a lot of drugs and stuff you think
I was pretty innocent at the time so I
didn't think so but probably yeah
had to have been that's the craziest
year you get all drugged up and you got
to count all your money and stuff and
walk home yeah well because I remember
all the tables they want you to take
shots with them yeah but I couldn't so I
was throwing them over my shoulder and I
got caught one day and then the guy was
super mad at me he took all the tip
money back then I quit really wow yeah
and so now you have your podcast yes you
work on BFFs yes
which I got to come on you did it was
cool it was cool I like it on there you
did yeah I would come back on Dave
hasn't invited me back on I know I
actually heard you wanted to come back
on I didn't think you liked it really
yeah I was getting a Vibe it wasn't your
Vibe no I thought it was pretty fun I
thought that it was fine you know I got
to meet that kid Josh I never met him
um I feel like you were kind of cold I
remember telling you that I think yeah
you know I didn't mean to be it seemed
like you did but that's just you know
maybe you're just awkward you know or
maybe you're just really cold
I I know I watched that clip and I'm
like ah that was tough yeah people are
cold sometimes you know yeah
um okay so then and you have a new show
too that you guys are promoting I just
saw right yeah I just filmed a reality
show and what is it is that legit or is
it just whatever it's like uh let's be
realistic dude
through barstools and bars okay barcel
does a bunch of reality shows
um I've been on a few of them I did like
the most dangerous game show that they
throw you in the woods they lock you and
like uh tubs of water oh wow I get that
crazy [__] but I didn't want to be on
them anymore so I just I pitched I'll do
one and I just um we put 10 influencers
okay in a house and we just made them we
made them go crazy and we made them turn
on themselves turning each other and the
prize is 25 000. oh wow okay so it's
like it's not one of those real ones but
so they're in it for a little bit of
bread yeah and how long did they stay
there for the weekend or something they
said that for seven days okay but we
were filming from like 5 a.m to like
midnight and they're all finished now
yeah the
um the finale comes out the 18th so I
don't know when this will be out but got
it
um that was a crazy experience I did it
with Josh
with Josh Richards yeah
do you like um being
um
do you think
like so what kind of stuff do you like
doing I mean obviously you like where
you are everything's going good and
maybe nothing needs to change
yeah sometimes there's always this
pressure like what are you gonna do you
know maybe I was even thinking about
asking you that but what do you like to
do
oh I just got into
um I got into my first writer's room the
other day actually
and it was so embarrassing because they
they had me in and Josh Richards he's
doing like a sketch comedy show so I'm
trying to get into more writing behind
the scenes type of stuff because I don't
really like being on camera and uh we're
doing all this riding around the two
first two hours we're good and then they
started asking me about like
dating and like first dates and uh like
random hookups and I I've never done any
of that stuff so I just started lying I
just started lying it was so awkward
really yeah it was so awkward I just
started making sure it wasn't awkward
for them because they thought I was
telling the truth but for me I was just
lying through my teeth and making up all
these stories and now I'm like I gotta
follow the lies hmm yeah it was bad
yeah I guess if you
if you don't
if you just yeah but can't you just tell
him it was a lie what is it for it was
uh it was just for like his sketch
comedy show they were like writing they
needed like research from women because
it's only men on the show although it
was like field research all the people
that work on the show are men yeah okay
yeah so they brought me in to help but I
didn't have the answers type of thing
yeah wow yeah but I don't know what I
want to do in the future I like you said
I feel like it's I'm kind of just
chilling yeah it's fun having a nice
time having a nice time yeah and what
about do you ever think about nursing
again sometime down the future PA in
um I mean it's a good backup plan yeah
yeah I mean like yeah I mean you could
do a million other things you know but
like I have some friends that are
comedians or entertainers and then once
they get a break like Joe Rogan says one
day he would like to go paint you know
he always wanted to paint he never got I
mean everybody wants to damn paint you
know everyone wants to do arts and
crafts like it was the funnest class at
school it's so fun but we all everybody
got caught up doing the other classes
you know no I'd want to do I'd want to
have like a sanctuary an animal
sanctuary oh my God
are you following huh what do you mean
are you following gold diggers with
animal sanctuaries are you on that
yeah every goal like there's so many
chicks out there it's like what do you
want to do and like I want to have some
um free-range dolphins in our yard like
there's some [__] out there that are
like I want to help people say raccoons
are so violent
they don't they've never treated them
the way I have [__] if two raccoons
[__] get near you and you're fine
Joe's juice they will beat the living
[__] out of here yeah that's true no I
want to have my own Sanctuary I don't
want to have anyone else's Sanctuary
okay and what kind of animals are we
talking over there and be honest like uh
cows horses
cows don't need a sanctuary dude yes
they do whatever ever passed a cow when
they're [__] having a tough time oh
no you save the cows that are going to
be butchered
Sanctuary
what do you want me to have you want me
to have like uh you want me to have like
Exotics I want you to have an animal
that needs some [__] help so you know
I'm saying like a sloth maybe get him
[__] hook him up with a motor skill
person or something you know or like uh
or rub a little bit of gasoline into
their first Something's Gonna help them
speed up a little okay but I think
accounts all they do they eat all day
they stand there they pass gas
throughout a great time they're like a
stepdad they're like a [__] fat
stepdad you know I don't think yeah you
can't have a rescue a cows in it dude
yes you can you could totally have a
rescue with cows in it come on they're
getting slaughtered every day [__] we
need them dog yeah I mean yeah I know
I'm not even a vegetarian or anything oh
come on you give me somebody imagine did
you see you break into somebody's
property and you steal a cow in the
middle of the night and you're like what
the hell yeah to save it you know
there's not that movie where that cow
gets like that's not so I think I like
your idea and I love your attitude but I
think part of it is just that idea well
the animal I don't know and I shouldn't
be telling you it's a bad idea it's a
sweet idea yeah no
um so so what is so a sloth I guess or
maybe like um animal needs it
well I tell you what neat animal needs
to be freed or whatever is zebras I mean
they put the bars on them [__] they
gotta [__] get those animals free dog
free zebras dude imagine walking around
where everybody thinks you're in jail no
matter where you are that's [__] yeah
okay so I would do zebras okay I would
do zebras see that kind of fits with you
too I think like here you go
there's a zebra she's rescuing it that's
kind of cool I think that's cool right
yeah but I would have to do I'd have to
do like ten it can't just do one that's
fine yeah I have to have a bunch of
zebras really you won't so you want and
is that the only animal you want or you
think more animals well I wanted cows
but I'm sorry so I guess uh you know I'm
a loss for that one I said horses Maybe
I don't know but they all seem like they
don't need help well horses a lot of
rich people are doing horses I think
there's a lot of bad they do yeah oh
yeah they'd be all rich around them yeah
whipping them and [__] riding them
you're thinking of slaves yeah I think
you're thinking of the wrong thing
you're reading the wrong books man yeah
but yeah maybe uh I've seen some rich
people's horses there's a guy and
there's a guy in Kentucky and I want to
have him on the podcast he owns like the
horse with like the best semen in it or
whatever and so he in the there's three
months out of the Year where they book
it like five times a day and there's
just a line of cars almost like to Field
of Dreams or whatever where they all
come in park yeah to go and punk to get
pumped by this horse and there's like a
club apparently there's a closed circuit
TV where like if you're like it's like
fifty thousand dollars for something to
have sex with this horse so oh they I
thought they were just pumping it off
and bringing so they have sex with the
horse yeah yeah
oh yeah it's not like easy serve or
whatever whatever that thing was I was
like what's going on I thought they were
pumping it off and then bringing the
semen to wherever they needed to no it's
not like a like a ice cream machine at a
drive-through that's how that's how it's
painted in my head okay so it's fifty
thousand dollars fifty thousand bucks
and they go in there and they pop and
they and that and then they do it they
the animals they do it or whatever
what's so good about this this guy he's
won all the races he's won enough races
okay it was like semen biscuit or
something what's that the guy's name
uh secretary maybe Secretariat
so that's a movie oh
this guy [__] all his secretariats I
know that dude this guy is like the
champion horse right he's just full of
unlimited team like if you even pet him
you get seized just leak and see and
it's valuable so there'll literally be
just a three a day and he's just all day
he's just in there God
I feel for him too so what's this guy so
what's the owner of the horse he's
living lavish
yeah I think last year on the horse they
made like 40 million dollars or
something
oh you got to get him on the Pod yeah
the horse needs to come on today that's
crazy 40 million yeah and he's just a
lucky guy he just had this horse he just
got lucky he get now he's been in the
system for a while but he was able to I
think get some horses that were other
grandparents and stuff and get like a
lineage you think he's sneaky look that
up Zach I think that that whole business
is really sneaky from what I hear like
people are like sneaking around their
horses are [__] in the middle of them
they're like oh let's meet these two
horses up like at a
I don't know a Ben and Jerry I'm not
like a benadry but like some place like
a something like that oh that's a sneaky
business yeah it's a sneaky business
does the guy does the guy that owns a
horse he's always wearing a suit
oh yeah huh yeah yeah and he just lets
the horse out like he's just letting out
to leak and then it runs behind the rest
area yeah and the other horses back
there
um
what are we talking about
oh my cows yeah yeah your animal
sanctuary yeah that's just that's just
that's a backup but where could you do
that in Southie could you do an animal
sanctuary in southeast
I mean yeah
walking by just smoking a door out just
looking in the fence like oh look at
these [__] sloths huh yeah you
could I feel like it'd do well honestly
I don't know those kids those people
never see that type of [__] they don't
leave Southie I don't know they'd be
like oh this sloth
this sloth uh yeah they would just like
keep comparing the sloth to like bad
quarterbacks that they've had yeah or
bad pitchers and uh that they've had in
Boston
yeah it'd be something like that it'd be
good I feel like it'd be good for the
community
the community yeah yeah sure yeah I
think it would they don't get to see
much they don't leave you come back
outside of your sloth as well [__] is
smoking yeah real slow
um
yeah I think that could be nice and now
I think a unique Boston Zoo would be
really great that's what I'm saying
right in the city well we got the
Franklin Zoo but they don't have much
there what happened they don't have much
really yeah it's like uh it's like the
bottom of the barrel we've got like two
two gorillas and then like hyenas they
have hyenas but they're in like the same
they're in the same thing they're like
coexisting it's sad they don't even sell
like they don't even have a concession
really
yeah no giraffes nothing oh like llamas
so it's like a petting zoo but they
Market it as it's like big Zoo but it's
really just my Zoo it's healthy like
that's what it is it's nothing they're
just there's a there's a soundtrack to
This play in the sounds of like of like
big animals in the distance yeah yeah
it's more like and then they just have
like a big reptile section oh yeah but
it's just like it just snakes the garden
snakes and it's always closed because
Donna got bit by something yeah two
employees
I got to go to the Wilbur there and
perform there and it's like the best
place ever oh it's the best Boston
people are the best dude yeah you like
them well I realize that your show
everyone at your shows they look like
you you think so there was a lot of
people I was like
that looks like even the women even the
women well I sat in front of it it
sucked I sat in front of the only person
in the whole entire place with a mohawk
the biggest [__] Mohawk it was so big
and I couldn't see I had to keep like
turning to try to see you guys but that
was a crazy the Mohawk was crazy I've
never really seen one of those in real
life but that was a woman oh yeah and
then the rest of the guys that kind of
looked like you it's hard to witness
um
Brad Kelly was
horse guy he's the owner
Brad Kelly was the horse guy how much is
it how much do they make off that horse
does it say how much on C
where does he live Lexington Kentucky
Franklin Ohio wow that's what you need
to get
yeah you get out there with a you start
if you start riding it if you meet a
good horse man you're in oh wow that's a
lot
of God can you imagine all that money
you could have what would you do with
that with that kind of money yeah let me
think
if I had as much money as
I don't know I wouldn't tell anybody I
don't think you can
having money is kind of embarrassing I
feel like you think so yeah I think
since you start like doing well you're
like embarrassed oh I've always I was
always embarrassed I was embarrassed
when I had nothing as a kid and then I
remember when I got a house like I got a
house in Nashville a few years ago and I
was embarrassed it's not even like an
amazing it's a nice house right but it's
nothing like
very extravagant or
um
you know it's a place you'd walk in like
oh this is a nice house right but it's
not a place you walk in like oh this is
like you know that's horse funny yes
that ain't horse money this is [__]
uh this is like that pony money that's
at the fair but like the world's
smallest Pony yeah like Tom Thumb or
something I saw him once out in
Riverside he is small
but
um
yeah I remember being embarrassed to
even show my own home really yeah
because there was something about
there's just something about about it
you should feel icky
but if it's the same icky I felt when I
was a kid that I was embarrassed to show
the apartment that we lived in yeah like
we had a toilet upstairs it was like
falling like right off to the edge of
the dinner table like this it was like
this perfect brown circle on the ceiling
like right near where the
dinner table was dude and so if we had
people over we would always like try to
like Lean Like This Way while we talk to
them so their eyes wouldn't like look
over at this huge like [__] piss
brown circle that was coming in through
the ceiling my bedroom my first bedroom
growing up it was it was a closet but
there was no window so like we couldn't
consider it a bedroom so my mom she
stapled curtains up on the wall to like
and she put a flashlight under to make
it like stuff the flashlight was stuck
behind like my bed on the floor with
these white curtains that you could see
through you could see it was just a wall
and it was I could I would never have
friends I had no friends because I was
like you can't come here yeah yeah yeah
if you come let's yeah and there you
guys are like hey I'm gonna sneak you
out tonight you're like all right I'll
sneak out through the window
it's a brick wall oh we got Sledgehammer
oh that's so crazy dude that's wild yeah
and I remember we had a bathroom there
was a bathroom upstairs and a bathroom
downstairs and the bathroom downstairs
was right next to the dinner table so it
was just like it was just the whole
place was just kind of a nightmare you
know yeah
it was funny though
we were always making fun of each other
and
what else was it like over there
they had a lot of stray animals in our
area she'd always if you went outside
you're always dealing with animals you
know in a bad way
yeah it wasn't like a petting it was
like a Threading Zoo like you just felt
like threatened constantly when you walk
outside it was like
yeah like a couple of [__] cats that
hadn't been fed would look at you like
it was your fault like [__] I just got
out here you know and you wouldn't want
to like eat dinner and then walk out
there because you think the animals
could smell it on you you know
so um but there would be like Dobermans
there'd be like just a couple of loose
brothers or freaking like tripped out
white dudes rolling around you just
didn't really know what was going on
there was always somebody cutting their
hair in the [__] Street it was always
like people burning like I lived in a
neighbor where everybody would just burn
stuff in the ditch right we lived right
outside of like the town limit
where you couldn't burn stuff in your
ditch right so it was a big thing like
people were like well at least we can
burn [__] in the ditch you know you
couldn't we could oh okay but like four
streets over they couldn't you know and
like look at these City Slickers you
know [__] driving their trash into
the over to the [__] yeah
we were just lighting it up
so I remember that that was kind of
interesting we had a lot of people that
couldn't read that would just break [__]
because they couldn't Express themselves
it's fair
I'm trying to think of what else we had
oh they had like writ like some
veterinarian would always drive through
our neighborhood and like they would
since we're outside of the Town limits
as well they would throw a lot of like
the animal carcasses and [__] like out
in our yard like the so we'd always be
out there like doing like paleontology
like playing games and [__] like that
like making like dinosaurs out of like
the old animal parts and like hot
burying them and then telling somebody I
was like I think there's a dinosaur and
they would start digging and it would be
like the shape of some weird animal we
never even like it was like a tail and
then like one foot and then into another
tail and you're like this I don't really
make any sense
yeah and two tails yeah so I think
things like like that's fun it was fun
yeah so like you were like you were poor
with stuff to do like I was just poor on
like a city road really yeah like we
would smoke I'm not we would drive
scooters and we would find cigarette
butts off the ground and just like smoke
them because it was cool but they were
dirty and then we'd be sick for like
three weeks yeah and it was like it was
just not fun I gotta have a park to go
to or anything really yeah no so what do
y'all do y'all get a Nintendo at home or
something uh yeah yeah I had a GameCube
oh that's good I had a game do you play
that a lot yeah monkey balls yeah it was
fun but I didn't have anyone to play
with really so I was just playing it but
so then what do you say but you what age
was that so but you didn't have any what
about your sisters though you guys
played together they were like so much
older than me oh yeah on drugs yeah so
no they didn't we didn't play I was like
basically an only child I guess with the
older with the older crazy ones that
would pop in and out and then we had we
had my aunt my uncle living in the
basement were they cool unfinishment no
really my one of my aunts kidnapped me
when I was two oh and I was gone that
little in the basement and then she left
and she went to Florida and she never
came back and my mom had to adopt her
two daughters
it was crazy that is crazy it was really
crazy so then they were around even
though their mommy kidnapped you yeah
they stayed around they my mom adopted
the two daughters and then the the mom
had kidnapped me but they found me the
same day they found me the same night
yeah talents would still yeah she said
she was just going to take me for a walk
hmm
yeah it's crazy what about for Halloween
and stuff what would you guys do uh for
Halloween we would drive down to the
suburbs and go visit my aunt yeah they
had some money down there yeah
boy and that's why I was my witch my big
witch and every year they'd be like oh
again yeah
and then I started doing the
hand-me-downs I started taking
hand-me-downs from my older cousin Molly
but then when my dog my dad got his big
mechanic job we moved down to the
suburbs so I like a split life oh so I
just like pretended I was fitting in and
stuff what company did he work with what
who did he get a job with he worked for
like the um it's called the MBTA it's
like the Transit Union of Boston so it's
like the train okay the buses and so he
repaired all the buses and trains yeah
he had like a salary right it was like
oh we can move now yeah
truck driver anymore like on and off
yeah yeah it was cool did he do
long-haul Trucking or no yeah he would
go he would he would be gone for I went
on a couple of them with him which was
crazy but he'd be gone for months at a
time really yeah it was cool that's a
long time big truck really yes and I
never knew the truck they have like full
beds in there I was sleeping on a full
bed and we would stop at the we'd stop
at the fairgrounds in New Jersey all the
time on the way home dude that had to be
fun it was so fun those are my best
memories yeah yeah those were cool what
do you remember any of the rides at the
fairgrounds was it like that like just
the different Rod to have like the
zipper and the Gravitron all of that the
zipper yeah and the the one where you
stick to the wall yeah that [__] was
cool Gravitron yeah I was just talking
about that last week yeah that was the
one and the guy in the center was like
playing rock and roll and there'd be
that one crazy guy that would like start
shimmying and do a flip stuck to the
wall the whole time that insane guy I
always wanted to be that guy yeah that
was fun
yeah that was fun
um what is your uh
deal like is your deal at barcel like
Caleb's it's just kind of like a flat
amount sort of thing is that okay to ask
you I'm not yeah that's fine um uh yeah
it's like it's like Caleb's like a
salary yeah
probably getting [__] but it's fun
yeah but I think they do a good job of
like
but you enjoy it though right yeah I
enjoy it so I don't even like it's
probably stupid in me but I have fun I
like Barstool and I with all these
influencers they do they make their
money off like brand deals so they don't
know when they're getting their next
checks and stuff right whereas I have a
salary so it's I don't know it's nice
it's really nice also what's not
sometimes what's like dealing with brand
stuff there's so many little things you
have to it's like so many extra
responsibilities that if you don't have
to think about that it's really nice
that's nice yeah you can just stick to
being yourself I know that uh yeah I
don't have to censor anything which is
cool yeah
and it seems like they treat you guys
good they do yeah yeah I love bar stool
everyone shits on it but I like it yeah
I don't know why but I mean I don't know
a ton about I mean I learned some about
it from Dave how he like went through
the business and put it together and
like some of the choices that they'd
made but it seems like a a good time it
is yeah people think it's very like
misogynistic but it's like run by woman
now so is it the pan or women
yeah well no but like the the top
performers at Barcelona are when are all
women they are yeah
who is it you
oh you just won this month you said huh
yeah do you have an employee of the
month I don't know I didn't even know
about it until
um I went to like I went to the acms
last week and I was like why am I here
why did you guys invite me and they were
like because you're the top Creator at
Barstool and I was like damn they didn't
even tell me that wow but but it's not
just me the chicks in the office like
it's full of women some people think
it's all run by men but it's not
um and they have Megan making money she
works there yeah I love her she's cool
she's awesome she's really funny
um and her husband I know her and her
husband he's crazy yeah they're the
craziest couple they're awesome though
yeah my stepdad is friends with his dad
really yeah okay they were friends
growing they're still friends but it's
like uh so it's kind of CR that yeah
that was all kind of crazy
um
what else was I gonna ask you about
do you have a favorite sports team that
you like
Celtics oh wow so you're stoked about
this then yeah
this is a big time are you gonna go to
do you think you'll get to go to any of
the games no way no what
what I'm not going to the games I would
love to but no way but what do you mean
no way like if you ask Dave he might
take you to one no way yeah he might
work there Dave me and Dave going to the
game together what the [__] are we gonna
talk about who cares no he wouldn't take
me to the game you don't think who
should I ask I gotta ask him I have BFFs
after that something about ask him yeah
I think you should ask him because
you're from there I am I could
understand
but that's their problem that's true
they're not you they're not an employee
of the month yeah okay
they're not employees okay I'll ask I'll
ask them
um
you got anything else that
I just feel like we've had a nice chat I
think we had a nice shot do you think
this went well this yeah yeah I think so
I think it's been interesting I feel
like I have a little bit more
understanding of who you are okay and
where you're from
um
and a little bit more semblance of your
personality so it's not just like when I
see you it's like I see you but I'll
still kind of have a maybe a slight
somewhat not understanding but a little
bit more clues okay
um and what else uh watch Project
verified project verified that's my
reality show project verified is your
reality show check it out check it out
and
um
yeah follow along what else can we think
about anything else
we had a dude boss growing up this kid
I'm not gonna say his name because he's
still alive but he um he would say
something and then he would say it again
under his breath say it again
yeah wow and we thought he was twins
that had never separated right so people
were like you [__] get your [__]
brother out of you oh [__] people would
[__] threaten to beat his brother or
sister out of him always under his
breath did he get over it huh did he get
over it yeah you get over but it was
crazy because then when people were like
we're gonna beat the [__] yeah he'd be
like help me and then you would hear it
again oh
oh no so people were like he is in there
and then it sounds like you're that that
they're [__] with him like he's like
being an [__] but yes it's just a
problem he has yeah dude it was a [__]
I feel so bad for that guy still
but his mother was awesome she was a
nurse she was a beautiful bigger lady
but damn she was [__] warm as could
be
oh I love a big warm lady don't you I do
would you what was your mother shaped
like
she got a little bigger after the knees
oh yeah that'll slow you down huh yeah
yeah she's she's petite she's like real
small that's too small for somebody
she's real small really they should put
her in that cage at the fair then
yeah come see the smallest knee knee
replacement I've picked him or whatever
sorry not victim come see the most
beautiful little knee replacement
woman in the world
um
is she a pretty happy lady your mom yeah
she's happy she's a happy lady she's uh
yeah she's a happy lady what are some
characteristics you guys that have that
are similar
I don't know if we have many I didn't
really so she I was with my dad growing
up and she was like uh her her like she
shows me affection through getting me
things or like making sure I'm good but
we're not like I couldn't just call her
and talk to her type of Mom right but I
know she loves me type of thing but I
can't just be like I don't call her and
tell her what's going on right type of
thing but she's she's a good lady yeah
yeah interesting yeah
um all right well
I don't know what else to say right now
you think we said enough of that
you think we've said enough
I think we said enough the flowers is
that good for you yeah it's good for me
okay thanks so much and uh appreciate
your time and congrats on
um your success and
um yeah and trying new things trying to
make a new show and
um and being in like a place that's kind
of like a man's place I guess but it's
more women's over there too yeah oh yeah
yeah and uh yeah thanks for uh sharing
your entertainment with us yeah thanks
for having
[Music]
gonna take